[Music]
you guys have a pretty competitive cast
is that right you guys just when your
cuz that's the difference with a show
like this you come in there's a work
that goes into it during the day and
then you do the show and it takes
exactly an hour to do it you guys
because you're working on this show
there's a lot of downtime a lot of
there's a lot of competition going on
yeah we have we have all sorts of
competitions who's the rudest and I
actually one who had the palest stomach
which no one thought I would win because
I was not even come up who has the
palest stomach I think I think Thomas
was getting miked and I was like wow
you're so much pretty pale not as pale
as mine he's like I doubt your stomach
is paler of the miming and so I pulled
up my shirt and a1 I mean you you look
pretty pretty pale I wanted to stand up
and victory cause oh yeah go for
oh you're proposing that we compare the
paleness of our skin yeah this is not
this is me with makeup so that I even
show up on camera people who see me in
real life are quite horrified so there
is no body makeup on me so why don't you
go and that's pretty pale okay
I think that's hair that's a manly hair
but if you find a part that has no hair
right there that's pretty white I might
win I don't know it's very hard to see
look at that with the light you know my
favorite thing is always imagining
someone tuning in right now it's just
it's just become a show where we scan
for skin cancers you know yeah that's
really nice I don't know who won there I
think we both lost
you